A key determinant of a successful review is how thoroughly
the participants examine the artifact. There are variety of means that have been
devised to encourage this thoroughness. Line by line coverage of, of the code or
the documents involved. similarly, if, if it's a, a diagram is being,
reviewed or going through systematically on the visual elements of a diagram.
If we're talking about the early stages, the requirements document,
it may be the use cases, and making sure all the use cases are going through.
Another technique for ensuring or promoting thoroughness comes at things from
a little bit different point of view. And this is a check list based reviews.
The checklist is based on common def, types of defects, either derived from
common industrial practices, or company specific empirical data. So for example,
if it's a code review there and the company has a history of problems with
correctly interfacing with libraries then it might be that you add a check list
for making sure that library interfaces are looked at a little bit more deeply.
And one, one other one is coverage of verification conditions.
This is kind of a specialized, checklist. Verification conditions
were invented as part of a clean room software engineering methodology by IBM.
A verification condition is a rule that obtains in a particular situation. For
example, when a loop is encountered during a code review,
a specific verification condition is to examine whether the loop is
guaranteed to terminate under all circumstances.